on to the topic homeless encampments in
Liberal Los Angeles have a brand new
amenity working washing machines yes
it's true vagrants are setting up
oversized tents and boasting about how
they can steal water and electricity
from the city in order to power their
own Street laundry service and in
California's other beleaguered liberal
City San Francisco a widely criticized
plan to build a single 1.7 million
dollar public toilet could be going down
the drain Governor Gavin Newsom
threatening to withhold the funds
because of the exorbitant price Jesse's
fiscal responsibility yeah that was a
big Prime Time Victory because we've
been pushing hard against this toilet
it's going to be three years to complete
a single stall public restroom uh not
made of gold it is a regular toilet and
it's costing about two million dollars
outrageous outrageous but we're going to
get that cleaned up
um the situation in was it Los Angeles
you have to let people hit rock bottom
because then they bounce back up demo
Democrats want to make rock bottom
comfortable yeah stay at Rock Bottom you
know put a washer dryer put a wine
fridge in there yeah do whatever you
need to spread out spread yourself out
that's the problem you're actually
hurting people by letting them fester
and squalor don't sit there and let them
do this to you because you're not
allowed to sleep on public property and
you're not allowed to sleep on private
property so get him the hell out of
there one of the huge problems with the
law in some of these places judge is
that they allow tents and tense means
more permanent basically you're
basically going to sit there yeah well
you know they have to change that that
zoning those ordinances those Municipal
ordinances uh but you know I want to go
back to the 1.7 million single stall
toilet in San Francisco I want to know I
wish I were the D.A in San Francisco I
want to know how much corruption how
many people got paid off who got paid
off to approve it at the zoning board
who got paid off to approve the bid who
got the bid who's hitting the plumbing
who's getting this contract I mean I
would love it just let me do one case
that's an outrage all right now back to
the what was your question no that's
okay on the encampments I think you made
the point
because tents are there it's just
they're so we're lucky in New York that
that's it's against the law and they
enforce it yes yes it's uh um but excuse
me sure you can get them you can get
them for um criminal not not stolen
property for using the electricity yeah
water you can prosecute them for that
unless they have permission from the
municipality they can't use that water
and that electricity that's just another
way to steal from the taxpayers if you
look at uh these kind of like you know
you know these nice public bathrooms
within months are destroyed and they're
destroyed by the homeless the what
upsets me and I in in a clumsy way Jesse
touched on it
um you could say that about pretty much
everything yes
um this idea of compassion creates this
problem it's false compassion it's a
phony virtue signal and it prevents the
necessary steps that are needed to get
these people off the street so their
idea of compassion is languishing on the
street overdosing uh becoming victims of
violence turning tricks whatever it is
we have to understand that affordable
housing and shelters is not going to
help for people who choose to live
outside Society the only thing we can do
is create an area where they can live
outside well actually my way wasn't
clumsy was concise after listening to
your explanation Carol would you like to
talk about the toilet or the washing
machine talk about Jesse's family
history
look I I'm torn on this too I mean I I
think we all know no one wants anyone to
be homeless and I don't think anyone is
wanting to to live on the street and no
one has said that I think
you want to live
well I think
if anybody normal right but but I think
they're normal people who fall into hard
times this is not the answer
all I'm saying is this is not this is
not the answer uh to to this problem and
Los Angeles past past a tax increase on
on its wealthiest residence a few years
ago to help build housing and they have
they have done they've only built like 3
000 units and they're spending a half a
million dollars a unit this is something
that's ridiculous it's absurd I agree so
we had we had to figure out we've talked
about this around the table figure out
figure out an answer and let's try our
hardest because it's probably two or
three answers people who are
is up next